à côtoyer régulièrement les mêmes choses
les mêmes personnes mêmes endroits
nous avons tendance à nous y habituer et
petit à petit à ne plus leur marque et
notre capacité d'émerveillement finit
par s'émousser
les détails du quotidien deviennent
visibles
l'auteur et aventurier français sylvain
tesson a écrit la capacité
d'émerveillement est un des secrets de
l'énergie vitale
chacun sait que les voyages sont
propices à stimuler cette énergie à
stimuler notre curiosité
dans ces quartiers historiques de
beijing vieux de 720 des touristes
affluent transportés sur des rich ou
pour une visite d'une vingtaine de
minutes j'ai demeuré une vingtaine de
jours habitué des grandes randonnées mes
pérégrinations photographe l'y
quotidienne m'amène à marcher entre 5 et
8 heures au bout de quelques jours les
habitants se sont habitués à mes allées
et venues quotidienne c'est ainsi que
j'ai découvert les boutons avec un
regard neuf
sans préjuger j'ai posé mon regard de
photographe sur les détails sur les
diversités du quotidien et les rituels
de la population à la manière d'un
voyage sociologique attentif aux détails
éphémère à la lumière dans les ruelles
étroites aux couleurs vives des
devantures des bazars et des petites
boutiques
m'est arrivé de respirer les effluves
des encens près des temples d'écouter
les chants des femmes dans les parcs ou
les conversations animées et des joueurs
de ma joue ainsi que les rires des
enfants sur le chemin de l'école dans
l'est ou tongs il se dégage une harmonie
naturelle du quotidien qui rythme la vie
des habitants
certains considèrent cela comme les
banalité du quotidien
mais c'est fait qu'ils paraissent sans
importance compose d'une mosaïque qui
regorge de moments de spontanéité qui
sont comme des portes ouvertes vers des
rencontres possibles qui me permet de
réaliser des portraits sur le vif dans
la rue et d'être témoin instant de
poésie urbaine
le quotidien ne se situe pas uniquement
sur une échelle de temps linéaire car il
se place aussi dans un espace multi
dimensionnelle de cet espace impose une
vision authentique sans artifice d'une
réalité sociale économique
mais d'une réalité culturelle où l'être
humain en est le coeur
par ailleurs le réseau de voisinage est
l'essence même de ce mode de vie il fait
partie intégrante des normes sociales et
culturelles
cependant les projets urbains se déploie
de manière exponentielle
les habitants sont déplacés à la
périphérie de beijing créant ainsi la
disparition d'un tissu social urbain
unique l'avenir des ou tongs semble
compromis coincé entre préservation des
traditions et modernisation heureusement
des organismes locaux nationaux et
internationaux se mobilisent pour la
préservation de ces quartiers où l'
architecture et le mode de vie se
considérait comme patrimoine historique
merci